«Батарейки, здавайтеся!» — це спільнота,
яка народилася в 2013 році для того, щоб об'єднати людей,
яким небайдужа проблема екологічного здоров'я України,
яке дуже сильно пов'язане з тим,
що велика кількість небезпечних відходів
викидається в нашій країні безконтрольно.
До цього моменту, поки я не почала цим займатися,
я навіть не уявляла, мені здавалося,
що є якісь спеціальні люди,
які контролюють екологічну безпеку.
Не може ж бути так, щоб просто свинець,
чи ртуть викидаються поряд з твоїм домом.
Але в Україні це може бути, на жаль.
І реально діючого органу контролю,
який би цим займався, його немає.
От така реальність.
Тобто може бути все, що завгодно.
І це показують дослідження, в тому числі ґрунтів України.
Тому ми вирішили взяти одну з найбільш популярних,
найпростіших тем — батарейки,
для того, щоб об'єднати людей і привернути увагу до цієї проблеми,
бо реально перша причина — це те,
що люди не розуміють, що вона в принципі є, ця проблема.
Лише одна пальчикова батарейка здатна забруднити
16 квадратних метрів землі,
і ви можете побачити, яка кількість батарейок
зараз тут є на нашому складі.
Ми відправляємо на переробку один мільйон батарейок.
Які у нас є зараз напрямки діяльності.
Перше — це безпосередньо організація збору і переробки батарейок.
Практичні дії, пілотні проєкти, як ми їх називаємо.
З одного боку ми їх робимо з великими торговими мережами,
коли переробка старих батарейок оплачується
із продажів нових батарейок.
Окрім цього ми залучаємо будь-які небайдужі компанії,
не обов'язково ті, які продають батарейки,
встановлювати коробочки в своїх офісах,
і збирати батарейки,
залучати до цього своїх співробітників.
Вони приїжджають до нас от в таких коробочках,
які встановлюють компанії.
Або якщо це відправляли волонтери,
і вони знаходять спосіб оплатити,
відправляють, наприклад, в пляшках.
Далі ми їх пересипаємо в спеціальні бочки для відправки на переробку.
Це спеціалізована тара,
вона пройшла випробування на міцність.
Її термін придатності всього лише п'ять років.
Далі її треба змінювати, щоби вони точно були стійкі.
Багато людей, волонтерів, тих, хто вже збирав батарейки,
мають це усвідомити, що ці наші практичні дії,
дуже важливо їх робити, але цього сильно недостатньо
для того, щоб вирішити проблему.
А для того, щоб її вирішити,
на рівні закону, так само, як в Європі,
ми маємо зробити так,
щоб за переробку батарейок платили їх виробники обов'язково.
Тобто, компанія, яка (у нас немає виробників батарейок в Україні),
компанія, яка ввезла батарейки, імпортер,
має бути зобов'язана забезпечити їх збір і переробку.
І тому другий напрям нашої діяльності,
те, чим ми займаємося,
це адвокація державної реформи.
Зробити цю систему обов'язковою для всіх.
Приблизно коли ми уже зібрали 20–30 тонн,
ми зрозуміли, що переробка батарейок платна.
Насправді всюди в світі переробка батарейок збиткова,
за неї потрібно платити.
Тобто вартість добутих ресурсів
не окупає вартість організації самої переробки.
І тому дуже важливо відповісти на запитання,
перш ніж збирати батарейки:
«А хто заплатить за їх переробку?».
І тому ми подумали: «А що нам заважає
звернутися до виробників в Україні?».
Вони ж десь є, ті, хто ввозять батарейки.
Ми їх зібрали на першу зустріч у 2016 році,
це було вісім компаній.
Із цих восьми компаній далеко не всі
погодилися працювати в такому ключі,
тобто прямо зараз частину свого прибутку
взяти і віддати на переробку.
Мені казали різні речі,
про те, що це ніколи не відбудеться в Україні.
Тобто, оця подія, яка зараз буде, відправка батарейок,
дуже багато людей казали, що це абсолютно неможливо,
і це ніколи не відбудеться.
Але за два з половиною роки переговорів
за участі деяких імпортерів, яким, правда, не байдуже,
ми прийшли до такої моделі,
що торгова мережа ставить це як умову
своїм продавцям батарейок.
Тобто, якщо ти хочеш продаватися у нас в мережі,
то у нас є такі от правила гри,
що ми скидаємось на переробку,
ми ставимо контейнери у себе
в мережі і скидаємось на переробку.
Ми почали з дослідження заводів, які вони взагалі бувають,
написали десь приблизно 15-ти заводам,
отримали відповідь десь від восьми.
І врешті-решт зацікавились
працювати з Україною буквально троє,
ті, хто взагалі нам відповідали і якийсь зв'язок тримали,
бо для них, треба розуміти, наші об'єми батарейок...
З одного боку для нас це «Вау!»,
ми от зараз один мільйон батарейок відправимо на переробку.
Але в масштабах європейського заводу
з переробки батарейок це просто смішно.
Найменший завод десь 700 тонн за рік переробляє,
ми зараз 20 тонн везем,
а, наприклад, в Німеччині завод «Redux»
переробляє 15 тисяч тонн на рік.
Поїхали подивилися вже вживу заводи в Румунії і в Польщі,
по великій кількості причин ми зупинились саме на Румунії,
і заключили з ними вже тепер договір.
І зараз у нас вже є 20 тонн оплаченого обсягу,
і ми відправляємо першу фуру.
Після цього вже в плані ще чотири фури.
Тобто з цифри нуль...
Бо до цього моменту жодна з українських батарейок
не перероблялась, це перший кейс.
Увесь цей збір батарейок зараз існував без переробки.
Ми найбільш божевільні виявилися,
що ми просто дійшли до цього кінця.
Ми спеціалісти битися головою об стіну п'ять років підряд,
але врешті-решт вона падає в якийсь момент.
Багато в чому це відбувається саме
завдяки підтримці людей і компаній.
Тому що, як я вже казала, у нас нема
якогось джерела фінансування,
це не комерційна організація,
і вся ця відправка — це не комерційна історія абсолютно.
Те, що ми можемо займатися цим як основною роботою,
пов'язане з тим, що люди розуміють свідомо, і підтримують.
І чим більше буде цих людей,
тим більше ми зможемо мати людей в команді,
щоб втілювати реформу.
Перший важливий практичний план для України — це
залучити ще декілька торгових мереж до збору.
Тому що запит від людей здавати зараз більший,
ніж можливість переробити.
Все починається з ідейної людини
в компанії, якій не все одно,
яка приходить до директора,
яка просто каже «давайте зробимо»,
і шукає не «чому ні», а «як ми це зробимо».
Такі люди є в Україні,
і ми їх поступово намагаємося залучити до нас.